how's it go breasts - so I found this
website called Drago art.com
it is an amazing website that teaches
you how to draw anything from fairies to
furries so I found this tutorial called
how to draw a hot girl so I want you to
close the door behind you in Lock put on
headphones because it's about to get
steamy so we're gonna draw this a hot
girl frame-by-frame
I'm genuinely going to try my very best
I'm not trying to draw [ __ ] just cuz
it's funny no we're in it for the boner
Amy for the to win it so let's start off
with step 1 start off by making head and
torso guys so in this sketch okay sounds
easy enough
okay I thought if I drew it fast like
the lines would be less [ __ ] hey that's
pretty good
alright you know what it's not terrible
I've definitely seen terrible error okay
step one complete step two and this step
all you have to do is draw out the right
side of the face or lining yourself you
can also draw any hairstyle you like
based on your preference all right so
we're drawing a hot girl here and that
means it's our fantasy and whatever we
like and whatever we think is a nice
haircut
we can make happen now I personally
really like dokas hair I think it
reminds me of when I was young and I
that's the hair I want and since the
tutorial allows it who were just gonna
[ __ ] stop me I'm not being funny I
genuinely think it's a sexy haircut I
don't know how many times I've asked
Marcia to to change her hairstyle into
Goku literally every time every time she
gets the new haircut I'm like well and
she's like hey how does it look and I'm
like well it ain't no Goku then she
starts
because I'm kidding okay so see that
looks pretty [ __ ] good all right step
three in this step you will continue to
work on the girl's face and add a little
detail on the ear then proceed to step
forward Wow
I am glad this tutorial told me to go to
step four after step three because if
they didn't I'd be completely lost
all right let's draw the ear and
whatever the [ __ ]
I love ass I love every kind of ass I
just want to hug them all but I can't
can't hug every ass
okay that's pretty good and let's move
on to step four essay tutorials so
clearly pointed out to it ooh
so now we're gonna begin working on the
eyes and blush marks on her cheeks now
the eyes are very important to make sure
that the girl looks as hot as possible
and yes so far I am nailing this [ __ ]
why does mine look like it's on drugs
what does mine look like something stuck
up her ass come on what did I miss
oh I know we didn't silly me
we didn't do the blushing yeah now
that's some [ __ ] hot [ __ ] [ __ ] man
alright moving on to step 5
if you haven't locked yourself in a room
yet I suggest you do it now
cuz it's about to get boobalicious oh my
oh my god how did that happen it looks
like a balloon that isn't blown up let's
do the titty [ __ ] sake come on so
instead of continuing the body we'll
finish drawing her long straight hair I
like how her hair is a bit rough and
shaggy looking because it makes her look
even hotter mine is definitely shaggy
looking and it is definitely not hot
alright it's time to move on to step 10
dad a yes do you feel a little bit of
tingling down there the ass is coming oh
my load look at that ass
let out a hair badass
yes oh god what happened it's not a
question mark or a butt crack I can now
this looks a little bit too pornographic
right now so we're gonna give her a pair
of pants don't flag this video this is
student art in progress all right there
it is now that's an ash [ __ ] nice it's
my uncle used to say whenever I would
bend over all right press are you ready
for the final result I would say that's
like 66 percent accurate and I think
that's pretty good for the first try you
know I'm saying all you need to do now
is color her in okay so let's let's
color her end oh my god it's gonna take
forever okay
and BAM boom BAM boom BAM nailed it
nailed that [ __ ] now let's say let's
tweet out and see what your brothers
think about it
I really think I did a good job on the
body like the body looks very nice
I agree the face is not the most
attractive one it's this my mom sweet
dude thanks for making this got a
jackoff now see that was the point
you're welcome is that the guy from
Dragonball question mark no it is not
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you the
boobs look more like a dick don't do
crack kids now what the hell is that
relate to my picture oh wait I see it
it's like before and after crack picture
like one of those her boob looks like a
dick why do people keep saying that
before a nut no what you brother mean
all right I try to do something for the
first time and maybe maybe it didn't
turn out the best all right but that
doesn't mean you should stop trying
because it's not about the result it's
about the journey thank you very much
this has been an honour to for me to
draw in front of you today but thank you
so much for watching let me know if you
want me to do more tutorials let's see
I'll show some other ones there's how to
draw anime body figures how to draw
Donald Trump so let me know in the
comments which one you want admitted
you're next and then leave a like and I
really appreciated you so much for
watching and as always stay awesome
breasts what are you doing don't draw my
girlfriend's nipples man that's that's
[ __ ] weird that looks like the belly
what happened